hey guys what's going on so today I'm
gonna be doing something a little
different I'm just gonna hop into it I
want to share a little bit more personal
side to me I'm gonna be performing live
music on September 5th at color my
energy hosted by Selina Meyers reject on
this channel and Jerry cooked up a beat
to this piano track I've been working on
it and I wanted to share with you guys I
wrote the lyrics and everything
hopefully I don't you know the hearty
dinner right now hopefully I don't
stumble on my words like I said it's not
perfect right now but I'm working on it
and I'll share with you guys what I got
so far
the really person that's like a
spiritual side to me so did you know
when I was young I actually had a lot of
fun family was dysfunctional difficult
to be faithful I would hear two sides of
God one would applaud the other was a
fraud but I on it the one who would
applaud something would protect me from
when it came to something holy my father
behaved beastly I wonder how I guess
right now I should thank my mom for
every sitcom I learned something
positive a feature distinctive humorous
persuasive elusive think about it what
is most attractive one thing you've got
to understand is that I don't feel
goddamned I express my heart through my
art but in reality there's all sites to
me which allows me to be free behave
proudly of who I really am cuz you only
understand the small milligram most of
the time I feel pretty damn good but I
don't believe in [ __ ] in the show it's
his right yet misunderstood I expressed
my feelings express my dealings
elsewhere let go of my bearings so when
I'm feeling upset while trying to
forgive and forget or quit repressing or
regret poetry then becomes my outlet I
believe in the power of trusting your
thoughts burn our brain thoughts as
people try to make us robots why they
gotta sugarcoat it why can't they just
be straight with it practically telling
us don't think like this don't think
like that don't feel this way don't feel
that way think realistic look at the
statistics we put so much focus on
career we've been struck with so much
fear no wonder no one's willing to
persevere they'd rather let their soul
disappear there's like voices everywhere
train all kinds of scares and we're so
unaware
life has become so unfair asking
everyone what should I do who should I
be is this okay that I feel this way to
everyone I have the same answer to what
you want to do be who you want to be
sounds easier said than done
trust me nothing will set you more free
it's funny how these voices so to commit
to a religion but yet they themselves
seem so joyless like in a bigger vision
and I'm saying religion is wrong seen in
a believer they read in Psalms the
lectures suffer the power of the Lord
and you will give you the desires of
your heart
yet people tell you don't pursue a
career in some type of art for girls and
guys for all types of faith
this applies asking you shall receive
when you ask do you really believe are
you thankful in advance believe there's
no miss chance or do you put out there
more desire for what you want to acquire
this now kick game cuz you're caught up
in sins do you believe your gimmicks
you're asking for do you believe God
still ignores desire is a powerful thing
but believe that it's on its way it's a
whole other thing ever notice unless
you're really attracting what you're
really feeling that's how you recreate
when you suppress that's giving you what
you want this ain't no game of chess
whatever to dream big reach of the stars
you ain't go so father get the nicest
car he can't be y'all but now only luck
gets you to become a superstar
we've been filled with so much doubted
something in us wants to shout because
we're so worn out it's like we trying to
satisfy everyone but ourselves
huh turn our let get put on the dusty
bookshelves I've done a lot of searching
a lot of studying I know a lot of you
are hurting your heart is just aching
just waiting for that break in just want
to know the truth of who you are I'm
telling you it you don't have to be
ruled by your scars a feeling is a
feeling good or bad with the labeling
your feelings you keep judging but
whenever your judge is still creating
it's still attracting manifesting a
feeling is the feelings of stuff Denine
and keep on feeling understand why you
feel that way decide if it wants to stay
every experience is necessary so
embraces all that the good the bad and
the ugly for to truly understand you
must experience its opposite so every
dark time it's gonna be a profit the
biggest epiphanies to date take full
responsibility suddenly everything
becomes clarity at the end of the day
you chose to belong to that pain I'm
telling you if you get a fool
if you do some rewiring of the brain God
is everywhere he is everything sounds
familiar will dive deeper because the
truth you ain't hearing we have this
idea that he's assisting being a
disapproves of the way we're thinking
the way we're feeling what we're doing
what we're saying how we're playing that
is rapping when vengeful is that he's
punished she likes him rewarding because
he's thinking were not deserving what if
I told you God just wants you to be you
to listen to your highest office that's
where he's communicating with you to
follow your heart cuz that's where he's
talking to you he tried to paint the
picture of God being a failure imagine
watching God decide I'm gonna create
another human then he says he's going to
be one of the evil children of course
not you've caught false thoughts God is
in you if God created you believing your
feelings and your thoughts cuz your soul
is the core of you your soul is what God
made you design how you wish to be
portrayed if God made you but he don't
love you that much we need [ __ ] up on
you but if you messed up how could he be
perfect think about it doesn't this
contradict God is not a separate being
through us God is living through us got
us experience and love is the encompass
of all emotions so God's with you when
the joy and the commotions don't wait
for God to change your life though just
sit still remember God gave you free
will if God determine your life in
advance how can you ever change your
circumstances tell me how was it free
will if there's only one path you wanted
to fulfill what if I told you what God
has planned for you is what you plan for
yourself all fears are learned all fears
are earned every emotion comes down to
love or fear but remember you are your
own puppeteer everything in your life
you somehow created embrace it all
imagine if there wasn't an emotion you
hated there's so much more I can say
haven't even scratched the surface of
what I believe I guess I'll have to save
it for another day I just pray these
words will be received
you guys thanks for listening if you're
in California come watch me perform live
when I have this song perfected Thanks